here's the other requirement
be willing to use deadly force if
necessary joining me now is kentucky
congressman thomas massey of the
judiciary committee congressman the
press is trying to spin this
the biden administration's narrative is
horrible this is completely backfired on
them this week but i get the sense that
uh
this is just the beginning of what we're
gonna see with this agency being turned
against the american people
yeah and not just this agency what a lot
of people may not realize is last week
the democrats through our judiciary
committee passed a ban on the ar-15 they
call it a weapon of war but they made
sure that their ban exempted every
federal department including the irs the
department of education in the usda
so you've got you got to put that in the
context of now this week tomorrow we're
going to be voting to add
87 000 irs agents to the rolls
and then taken with this website and
like you showed look they got caught
they had this on their website i went
and looked at the internet archives they
put it up since biden became president
that you must be willing to do deadly
force you know to exert deadly force
and they just took it down yesterday
because they got caught
recruiting that way and by the way laura
i've talked to people who spent their
life in law enforcement they said this
is the last thing you would put in a job
posting you get the wrong kind of people
if you say you want to kill people join
us
i mean the border patrol can't even use
deadly force pretty much right so border
patrol no but the but the irs yes that's
a twisted world we're living in now the
new atf director actually sat down with
cnn today watch this
he sat down with cnn to discuss the
litany of threats his agents are trying
to counter from coast to coast including
a rise in violent domestic extremism
i think the first thing we need to do is
to is to be honest about the fact that
we have we have a problem but i will
tell you
it's gotten more
bold
more brazen and more violent
uh your response to that we apparently
have a massive domestic terror problem
in the united states and they all just
happen to be trump supporters
congressman
yeah you know we we've asked the doj
about this they put the dhs actually put
out a bulletin that said that uh
if you do certain things like you deny
things about the vaccine that you may be
a domestic a violent domestic terrorist
or you know it's crazy maybe you grow
your own food now you're going to be
labeled as such
it's it's crazy what can put you on this
list and i think it's dangerous well
it's time to defund the agencies that
are targeting the american people that's
what we're going to be expecting of
congress when republicans take over
congressman you've been a beacon thank
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else